Rescue workers in Morocco have been working
tirelessly for days to save a five-year-old boy
who fell into a well. Crowds have
flocked to the village of Ighran to
cheer on the rescuers. Officials
say they are getting close to the
boy - but that conditions are dangerous
and the rescue is in a challenging phase.
Throngs of people watch as rescuers race
to save a boy's life. Little Rayan has been
stuck 32 meters down this well since Tuesday.
"He was playing until the middle of the day.
He was with me at first, but then I
looked for him and couldn't find him.
After searching we realized that he fell
into the well. Now we are praying to God."
At less than half a meter wide, the well is
too narrow to pull the boy out. Rescuers use
ropes to lower oxygen and water as well as a
closed-circuit camera to check on his health.
On Thursday, a rescuer was
able to go down a parallel hole
that had been dug to get closer to Rayan.
"I managed to communicate with the
child and asked if he could hear me.
There was a response. I waited for a minute
and saw that he began using the oxygen."
Once rescuers were able to dig down to the depth
where Rayan is stuck, they began excavating a
horizontal tunnel to try and reach the boy.
But the loose soil has slowed their efforts.
Gripped by the boy's terrifying plight,
many have come to cheer on the rescuers,
or even to volunteer. But authorities have
asked them to stand back and let them work.
"Many people from the region
came to the site of the accident
and some even spent the night there. Little Rayan
touched them and everyone is praying for him."
Officials said on Friday that they were
just meters away from reaching Rayan.
A police helicopter is waiting to take him
to the hospital as soon as he is freed.